you can't escape corn our modern society
is completely dependent on corn and all
of this corn is secretly making us sick
fat it's destroying the environments
while systematically robbing us of our
money but Bitcoin doesn't want you to
know any of this why because money they
don't want you to know that the corn
industry is worth 86 billion dollars or
10 billion dollars more than the tobacco
industry they don't want you to know
that high fructose corn syrup is
secretly making you fat even though
there's literally no reason to be using
high fructose corn syrup over natural
sugar and they don't want you to know
that corn is the most subsidized crop In
America which is a nice way of saying
money is coming out of your pocket in
the form of taxes and straight into the
pockets of big corn